David Boder: [In German] Sie sprechen ganz einfach und richten Sie Ihre Stimme ungefähr in diese Richtung, so—in jede Richtung, nur nicht ganz weg, nicht wahr!
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, das sehe ich schon.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
David Boder: [In English] Paris, August 19, 1946, at the Offices of the American Joint Distribution Committee. The interviewee is Mr. Friedrich Schläfrig, 71 years old. He is here with his wife planning to go to South Africa and is expecting at this moment a telephone call from Lisbon for clearance on the ship. He graciously agreed to be interviewed.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Schläfrig,...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: [In English] May I speak English too?
David Boder: [In English] Oh! He says he may speak English...
David Boder: [In German] Aber es geht besser auf deutsch, nicht wahr? Wir wollen das Beste nehmen, nicht wahr? Und ich frage sie dann und wann was in englisch. Also, Herr Schläfrig, wollen Sie uns Ihren vollen Namen sagen und von wo...wo sind Sie geboren?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich heiße Friedrich Schläfrig und bin geboren in Mistelbach in Niederösterreich.
David Boder: Wie alt sind Sie jetzt, Herr Schläfrig?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich bin jetzt im zwei und siebzigsten (72) Jahre.
David Boder: Was ist Ihr Beruf?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich bin Architekt von Beruf und war Ministerialrat im österreichischen Eisenbahn Ministerium.
David Boder: Wann waren Sie Ministerialrat im österreichischen Eisenbahn Ministerium?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich war im...bis zum Jahre drei und dreißig (33).
David Boder: Also, Herr Schläfrig, wollen Sie uns dann erzählen, schrecken Sie nicht von Einzelheiten zurück, es ist besser für uns, dass wir einen kleinen Sektor Ihrer Geschichte mit allen Einzelheiten haben, als dass wir im Umriss das Ganze haben. Und Sie haben ja noch Zeit, wir können vielleicht noch am Nachmittag zusammen kommen.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Oh ja. Ich bin noch da.
David Boder: Und wir können vielleicht auch mit Ihrer Frau Gemahlin reden.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja.
David Boder: Also wo waren Sie als der Krieg anfang...anfing und wie ist es Ihnen gegangen? Gehen wir!
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Wenn der Krieg anfing, lebten wir in Wien. Ich wurde am ersten...noch vor...noch bevor der Krieg angefangen hat, war ich deswegen in einer unangenehmen Situation, weil ich beim Einmarsch Hitler’s in Österreich im März neunzehn hundert...neunzehn hundert acht und dreißig (1938) Präsident der B’nai B’rith Loge Eintracht war.
David Boder: Oh! Warten Sie Mal, Herr Schläfrig, wollen wir das doch chronologisch machen. Wollen wir hier den Krieg nehmen von der Zeit, wo die Nazis übernahmen in Österreich und den Anschluss, und so weiter. Das wollen wir für Sie die Kriegszeit nennen.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das Ganze.
David Boder: Ja. Nun? Sie waren, hm, hm...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich war damals, ich war im Jahre neunzehn hundert acht und dreißig (1938) zum zweiten (2.) Mal zum Präsidenten der Loge Eintracht gewählt worden.
David Boder: „Eintracht“ sagen Sie?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Eintracht in Wien, in Wien’s größter B’nai B’rith Loge.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und in diesem...die, die Juden Österreich’s haben sich selbstverständlich auf Seite ihres Kanzlers, des Schuschnik, gestellt, weil ja die nazistische Propaganda zunächst die Juden in Österreich bedroht hat.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Es ist selbstverständlich, dass man alles getan hat, um das selbstständige Österreich zu erhalten und die Regierung zu stützen soweit unsere Kräfte gereicht haben. Das hat dazu geführt, dass man zu der Zeit, wo Schuschnik eine Volksabstimmung in Österreich machen wollte über die Frage des Anschlusses an Deutschland. Dass man natürlich diese Volksabstimmung, diesen Volksentscheid, der ja vorbereitet werden musste, auch materiell vorbereitet werden musste mit den Mitteln der B’nai B’rith und mit anderen jüdischen Mitteln unterstützt hat. Ich persönlich war an diesen Dingen beteiligt und ich habe nicht gewusst, weil ich diese betreffende Zeitungen nicht gelesen habe, dass am Abend des Einmarsches, hm, Hitler’s mein Name...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: mit anderen Namen als der, der prominenter Juden, der die Regierung Hitler’s...die Regierung Schuschnik’s unterstützte, genannt war, dass meine Tätigkeit in einem langen Zeitungsartikel dargestellt war und ich also sodann—schon dann politisch ausgeliefert war.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie mal fortsetzen.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Folge davon war die, dass ich über Nacht dieses Abends, dass ich in dieser Nacht verhaftet wurde und mit einer ganzen Anzahl von Prominenten von B’nai B’rith einer,...einem politischen Verhör—einem Nachtverhör unterzogen wurde. Man hat unsere Verbindung mit kommunistischen Parteien—in erster Linie mit Moskau—vorgehalten bekommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . man hat uns dessen beschuldigt.
David Boder: War das wahr?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Also gar keine Idee! Man hat unsere Korrespondenzen mit Moskau gesucht, man hat unsere Archive durchsucht, man hat fortwährend nach Verbindungen mit New York und nach unseren Verbindungen mit den „Weisen von Zion“ geforscht und wir...
David Boder: Man nennt das bei uns in englisch: „The Elders of Zion“.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . und wir sind—nachdem dieses Verhör bis zirka drei (3) Uhr morgens gedauert hat—sind wir in das Polizeigefängnis überführt worden...
David Boder: Wie hat man Sie behandelt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat—es hat natürlich an persönlichen...an physischen Misshandlungen nicht gefehlt, wir sind...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: wir sind geschlagen worden mit diesen...mit Gummiknüppeln.
David Boder: Auch Sie persönlich?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Auch ich persönlich. Man hat uns in diese geschlossenen Kastenwagen, wie Vieh hinein geworfen und ins Polizei Gefängnis überführt, wo wir die Nacht...wo wir die Nacht verbrachten. Am nächsten Tage wurden wir, hm, wurden wir in die einzelnen Zimmer verteilt und, hm, wie eben gewöhnliche Sträflinge untergebracht in einer Zelle untergebracht. Ich persönlich war mit sechs (6) anderen Mitgefangenen in einer Schwerverbrecherzelle untergebracht, die ungefähr ein Ausmaß von drei (3) auf drei (3) Meter hatte.
David Boder: Wo war Ihre Frau Gemahlin noch?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Meine Frau blieb zu Hause.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Blieb verhältnismäßig unbehelligt während dieser Zeit. Die ganze Zeit, die ganzen Wochen waren mit wiederholten Nachtverhören ausgefüllt, man hat uns immer nachts mit dem „Grünen Heinrich“, diesem geschlossenen Kastenwagen abgeholt, hat uns zur Polizeidirektion, hm, zu Nachtverhören gebracht und in der Früh hat man uns wieder nach Hause vom Gefängnis entlassen.
David Boder: Herr Schläfrig, wie alt waren sie da?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Damals war ich 63 Jahre alt.
David Boder: Nun. Und so wurden Sie jede Nacht verhört. Wie lange hat das gedauert?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das hat...das hat zwei (2) bis drei (3) Wochen gedauert. Ich will nicht sagen jede Nacht, aber ein großer Teil, ein großer Teil diese Nächte ist mit Nachtverhören verbracht worden.
David Boder: Also, Herr Schläfrig, wollen Sie uns eines von diesen Verhören, so nah wie möglich, repräsentieren. Was hat man Sie gefragt? Was haben Sie geantwortet und so weiter?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Fragen, die Fragen sind deswegen ziemlich belanglos, weil ja ein großer Teil dieser Fragen sich auf persönliche Auffassungen beschränkt hat. Man hat versucht heraus zu bekommen, welche politische Einstellung der Einzelne hat, ob es sich nicht irgendwie in Widersprüche, in Widersprüche verwickelt, um doch heraus zu bekommen, dass eigentlich die B’nai B’rith eine politische, kommunistische oder ansonsten einen anrüchige Vereinigung sind...
David Boder: Amerikanisch?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . ja, amerikanisch, also jedenfalls was, was gegen das, hm, herrschende Regime gerichtet war und wo man die Leute glatt konnte dann politisch oder vielleicht auch physisch unschädlich machen. Es ist nicht gelungen von einem einzigen Verhafteten aus den Kreisen der B’nai B’rith irgend eine Bestätigung heraus zu bekommen, die diese Befürchtungen oder Vermutungen oder Beschuldigungen, hm, bekräftigen können. Man musste uns nach kürzerer oder längerer Zeit doch entlassen. Freilich war die Entlastung, die Entlassung...
David Boder: Konnten Sie Advokaten engagieren?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Meine Frau hat sich bemüht nicht, hm, nicht...nicht jüdische Anwälte, einen nichtjüdischen Anwalt dafür zu gewinnen und das ist auch gelungen. Und ein nazistischer Anwalt hatte es erreicht, dass ich gegen Ende März aus der Haft entlassen wurde.
David Boder: Also Sie waren von wann...bis?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Also ich denke zu sagen zwischen zwei (2) und drei (3) Wochen waren es.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Also Anfang April...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . war ich wieder zu Hause.
David Boder: Nun?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Diese...die Folgenden...man konnte gegen...man konnte gegen keinen Einzigen von uns irgendwelche positive...positive Anschuldigungen erheben. Keine waren begründet. Wir sind also in Intervallen nach Hause entlassen worden. Die Zeit allerdings, des Zu-Hause-Seins war insofern eine Schwer-Tragbare, weil man keine Nacht vor Haussuchungen sicher war.
David Boder: Ja, haben Sie Kinder, Herr Schläfrig?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, ich habe einen Sohn, der zu dieser Zeit schon in Südafrika war.
David Boder: Oh! Fahren Sie jetzt zu Ihrem Sohn?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich fahre zu meinem Sohn, der seit dem Jahre sechs und dreißig (36) schon in Südafrika als Architekt arbeitet.
David Boder: Als Architekt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja.
David Boder: Hat er in Wien beendet?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Er hat in Wien studiert, beendet und ist im Jahre sechs und dreißig (36) nach Südafrika ausgewandert.
David Boder: Das ist Ihr einziges Kind?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das ist mein Sohn. Meine Tochter lebt derzeit in Kanada.
David Boder: Aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die ist zu dieser Zeit mit uns in Wien noch gewesen, ist...hat es dann vorgezogen Wien zu verlassen und ist als...in häusliche Dienste nach England gegangen, wo sie als, als...wo sie im Hausdienst bei einem englischen Baron...wo sie in der Familie des englischen Baroness sehr (unverständlich—beide sprechen)
David Boder: Also die konnten Juden nehmen, die englischen Hausdienst leisten?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Engländer haben die arischen Bediensteten aus Deutschland und Österreich entlassen und haben vielfach jüdische Be...
David Boder: Bedienstete.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . jüdische Kräfte also—Mädchen in erster Linie aus jüdischen Häusern in ihre Häuser aufgenommen.
David Boder: Also was für eine Bildung hat Ihre Tochter gehabt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Meine Tochter war...hat Mittelschule und Kunstgewerbe absolviert. Sie ging...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: Ja und sie ging als...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Sie ging als Parlor Maid.
David Boder: Parlor maid...Parlor maid. Wo ist sie jetzt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Sie ist jetzt in Kanada verheiratet und denkt daran...ich hoffe, es wird in kurzer Zeit möglich sein, mit uns zusammen in Südafrika in Johannesburg zu leben.
David Boder: Aha. Ich werde Ihnen später welche Grüße übergeben müssen nach Johannesburg.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Sehr gern!
David Boder: Also haben Sie den Dr. Weiler hier gesehen, den Rabbiner von Johannesburg.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Nein.
David Boder: Er ist hier in der Stadt.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: So?
David Boder: Den müssen Sie sehen, wenn er noch hier ist.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja.
David Boder: Vielleicht kommen Sie mit mir mit nach meinem Hotel später, wenn wir fertig sind und dann...
David Boder: . . . kennen sie ihn, der ist ein großer Mann dort und der ist jetzt hier, gerade hier.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja.
David Boder: Er wird Sie auch dort gebrauchen wahrscheinlich.
David Boder: Nun sehen Sie mal. Also wie war es dann? Sie sind nach Hause gekommen und da waren Haussuchen.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Es waren viele Haussuchen, da hat man...
David Boder: Was haben sie gewollt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat nach Waffen gesucht und unter dem Vorwand der Waffensuche hat man eigentlich alles, das irgendwie nach der Möglichkeit eines Verstecks von Wertsachen ausgesehen hat, eben halt durchsucht. Es sind Wertsachen einfach mitgenommen worden, man hat sie beschlagnahmt unter dem, unter, unter der Mitteilung, dass die bei der, bei der Gestapo jederzeit angefordert werden können und man hat tatsächlich ist das, dass ein großer Teil des Schmuckes, alles was etwas Wertvolleres war, verschwunden ist, dass es einfach mitgenommen worden ist, dass man in Wohnungen, wo die Inhaber nicht freiwillig ihre, hm,...gezeigt haben, was sie besitzen, alles durchsucht haben, lederne , hm, gepolsterte und led...lederne Möbelüberzüge zerschnitten hat, die Polster durchsucht hat, um heraus zu bekommen, ob nicht irgendwo Schmuck, Perlen und Brillanten und Wertsachen verborgen sind.
David Boder: Nun?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das ist in meinem Hause, bei anderen Parteien geschehen; bei mir selbst haben sich die Leute begnügt das mitzunehmen, was sie eben im Tresor gefunden haben und sonst an Wertsachen.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: In dieser Zeit war es schrecklich, weil man nie wusste, wann man wieder verhaftet wird. Man ist ja wiederholt verhaftet worden. Es ist mir drei (3) Mal passiert, dass ich verhaftet worden bin. Allerdings bin ich auch...auch die übrigen zwei (2) Mal ebenso entlassen worden und habe ich Wien gelebt vom Jahre neunzehn hundert und..., hm, vom Einmarsch Hitler’s im Jahre neunzehn hundert acht und dreißig (1938) bis zum September neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig. Allerdings konnte ich meine Wohnung nicht behalten. Die Häuser mussten wir verkaufen, in einem meiner Häuser hatte ich die Wohnung, die musste ich natürlich auflassen. Wir mussten uns dann an, in...in möblierte Zimmer zurück ziehen, immer enger und immer enger. Ich bin während dieser drei (3) Jahre fünf (5) Mal übersiedelt.
David Boder: Hat man für die Häuser bezahlt, die Sie verkaufen mussten?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Häuser sind bezahlt worden mit einem Bruchteil, etwas mit dem vierten (4.) oder fünften (5.) Teil ihres wahren Wertes.
David Boder: Wer hat die gekauft?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Häuser haben Leute gekauft, die von der Partei eine...
David Boder: Eine Bescheinigung?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . Sanktion sozusagen haben mussten, dass sie um die Partei sich Verdienst gemacht haben, also wert sind jüdischen Besitz zu bekommen...zu billigem Geld.
David Boder: Ja und?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: So sind die Häuser verkauft worden. Wir sind...wir haben, wir haben uns für eine Übersiedlung nach Südafrika vorbereitet gehabt bevor wir unsere Wohnung verließen. Leider ist aus dieser Übersiedlung nicht geworden, weil ich die Permit für Südafrika, trotz der Bemühungen meines Sohnes, der zu dieser Zeit noch nicht naturalisiert worden ist und noch nicht werden konnte. Auch meine Tochter konnte, hm, die nach Südafrika gehen wollte, konnte nicht. Wir haben dann versucht nach Australien auszuwandern, auch dort konnten wir den Permit nicht bekommen. Alle Auswanderungsversuche, die Versuche mit Hilfe der amerikanischen Logen, eine...ein, hm,...
David Boder: Ein Affidavit zu bekommen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . ein Affidavit für, für Amerika zu bekommen, haben sich so lange hingezogen bis die Verhältnisse für die Ausreise nicht mehr möglich waren...bis in den Beginn des Jahres ein und vierzig. Das ist dann das ganze System der Einwanderung nach den USA geändert worden und ein neues System innoviert worden, dass den Wenigsten die Möglichkeit gab nach Amerika zu kommen, obwohl ich zu dieser Zeit bereits ein Affidavit hatte.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Wir mussten als, wir mussten da also noch versuchen—durch meine Verwandten in Amerika habe ich da versucht—nach Kuba zu gelangen...auch das, auch diese Möglichkeit konnte nicht realisiert und im August des Jahres ein und vierzig (41) wurden wir verständigt, dass wir mit unserer Deportation...also mit unserer Deportation...mit unserer Evakuierung aus Wien zu rechnen hätten...in den nächsten Wochen.
David Boder: Wer hat Sie dazu verständigt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Da hat mich die Kultusgemeinde verständigt...ich habe ja durch Jahre als Vorstand der Kultusgemeinde als gewähltes Mitglied angehört in Wien und habe eben meine Bekannten dort gehabt und die haben mich eben verständigt, hm, dass es, dass wir in den nächsten Wochen deportiert würden.
David Boder: War das deren Pflicht, oder Sie haben es Ihnen bloß sagen wollen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Nein,...ich habe es erfahren, net wahr, dass es mir kaum mehr möglich sein in Wien zu bleiben. Man hat nur gesagt, es werden alle Juden aus Wien deportiert, das hat sich als nicht richtig heraus gestellt, aber ich...
David Boder: Falsch.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . aber immerhin wir mussten damit rechnen. Tatsächlich sind wir mit einem Transport am achten (8.) September ein und vierzig (41) nach...nein zwei und vierzig (42), Verzeihung...das ist alles statt ein und vierzig (41)—zwei und vierzig (42), bitte. (beide sprechen)
David Boder: Ja, wir werden das korrigieren...
David Boder: [In English]...forty-one (41) date is forty-two (42).
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, was hat die Kultusgemeinde mit der Deportation zu tun gehabt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Kultusgemeinde hat, hm, hm, es auf sich genommen, hm, die Leute auszuheben und bereitzustellen für den Transport. Man hat gedacht, ich weiß nicht, ob es richtig war, man hat gedacht, wenn die Juden es selbst machen, dann wird es in einer menschlicheren Form geschehen.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ansonsten würde es ja müssen die Gestapo selbst machen. Nun scheint die Gestapo keine Lust gehabt zu haben, das auf ihr Konto zu nehmen und hat es viel bequemer gefunden, die jüdischen, hm, die jüdischen Institutionen vorzuschieben und die Juden diese Aushebungen machen zu lassen. Tatsächlich hat die Kultusgemeinde ihr ganzes Personal in den Dienst dieser Aushebungen stellen müssen.
David Boder: Wer war der Direktor der Kultusgemeinde?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das war Löwenherz.
David Boder: Dr. Löwenherz? Josef Löwenherz.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Dr. Löwenherz? Josef Löwenherz.
David Boder: Josef Löwenherz, ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und die Kultusgemeinde hat ihr ganzes...
David Boder: Wo war der Dr. Friedmann gewesen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Dr. Friedmann war in Wien und Stricker war auch in Wien.
David Boder: Wo?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Beide in Wien. Eine Zeitlang, hm, eingekerkert, sind dann auf freien Fuß gesetzt worden, waren aber unter ständiger Aufsicht der Gestapo und mussten sich wöchentlich melden.
David Boder: Melden. Wer—was war der andere Name?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Friedmann und Stricker.
David Boder: Stricker.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Stricker, der institutionstechnische, ehemalige Nationalrat und...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . und Vorstand der Kultusgemeinde. Stricker und Friedmann, beide befanden sich auf freiem Fuß, hatte eine Wohnung—eine ganz nette Wohnung in der Stadt , in der ich sie öfter besucht habe—standen aber unter Polizeiaufsicht. In der Kultusgemeinde waren die massgebenden Personen Löwenherz und in der letzten Zeit namentlich Dr. Murmelstein.
David Boder: Murmerstein?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Murmelstein, der ehemalige Oberrabbiner der Kultusgemeinde, und der in Theresienstadt eine wenig erfreulich Rolle gespielt hat und, wie ich gehört habe, von den Russen und von den tschechischen Gerichten zu achtzehn (18) Jahren im Gefängnis in Prag...
David Boder: (unverständlich)
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . verurteilt worden sein soll.
David Boder: Nun und...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Diese...die Kultusgemeinde selbst hat also diesen,...den Dienst der Aushebungen organisiert. Und zwar mit ihren eigenen Kräften. Alle die Bediensteten von der Kultusgemeinde mussten sich auch dazu hergeben—mit etlichen Ausnahmen haben es die Meisten getan—ich bedauere es, dass ich das sagen muss—deswegen getan, weil sie...damit ihre—wie soll ich denn sagen...
David Boder: Ihre eigene Person?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . ihre eigene Person verschont glaubten. Tatsächlich sind sie geschützt geblieben bis in die allerletzte Zeit...bis in den Winter zwei und vierzig(42), drei und vierzig (43) hinein.
David Boder: Also Sie wurden informiert, dass die Deportation kommt. Was haben dann getan?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . ; dass die Deportation kommt. Wir haben, wir haben...
David Boder: . . . das war in zwei und vierzig (42)?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: ja nicht mehr viel...wir haben ja nicht mehr viel besessen. Wir sind ja durch die vielen Übersiedlungen ja immer ärmer geworden. Haben das Notwendigste in unsere Koffer verpackt und haben uns für unsere Reise fertig gemacht. Sind dann tatsächlich am siebten (7.) oder achten (8.) September mit einem Transport von Wien nach Theresienstadt abgesendet worden. Es sind...
David Boder: Wie ist man gekommen? Und wie hat man Ihnen das wissen lassen? Was hat da passiert, ich will die menschliche Seite von der Sache haben, wie hat man Sie informiert darüber?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Diese...dieser, dieser Transport hat sich verhältnismäßig menschlich vollzogen, weil ich dadurch, dass ich freiwillig eingerückt bin auf die erhaltene Verständigung...
David Boder: Aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat mich ja vorher, hm, ausgehoben gehabt...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Da sind sie ja schon vorher schon eingehoben worden und zwar in der Art, wie sie in Wien Gang und Gebe waren. Es ist ein Haus besetzt worden von Angestellten des Aushebedienstes der Kultusgemeinde.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat das Haus abgesperrt...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . in jedes Stockwerk einen dieser Ausheber dirigiert...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Der hat die Leute in den einzelnen Wohnungen—die Wohnungen waren dicht bewohnt, weil in jedem Zimmer mindestens zwei (2), manchmal auch drei (3) und vier (4) Personen gewohnt haben, jede...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . so dass in einer Wohnung von vier (4) bis fünf (5) Zimmern zwanzig (20)...oft zwanzig (20) Personen gewohnt haben.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat also diese Leute dann alle in ein (1) Zimmer gebracht...
David Boder: Ja,...die Leute der Kulturgemeinde?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . durch die Leute der Kultusgemeinde—ein Organ in jedem Stockwerk...
David Boder: Einen Repräsentanten?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . ja Einen in jedem Stockwerk...und hat ihnen...und hat sie warten lassen bis ein Organ der Gestapo gekommen ist.
David Boder: Das mein...das heißt ein Beamter?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, nicht ein Beamter...ein Gestapo, hm,...Mensch...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . ein Organ der Gestapo, irgendein Scharführer oder ein Sturmführer oder was er sonst war...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . der hat nun das ganze Haus von oben bis unten durchgegangen und hat Jeden angeschaut in der Richtung und hat entschieden, ob der Betreffende zu deportieren ist oder ob er hier zu bleiben hat.
David Boder: Aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Auf welcher Basis dieser Gestapo...dieses Gestapo Organ das entschieden hat, wer sofort zu packen hat...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . und wer in der Wohnung verbleiben kann
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Leute, bei denen entschieden worden ist, dass sie zu packen haben, haben sich sofort und mit Unterstützung dieser Organe der Kultusgemeinde, des Aushebedienstes, haben sie sich daran gemacht ihre Effekten reisefertig zu machen.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Haben in der Nacht noch alles zusammengepackt und mussten gewöhnlich in der Früh um sechs (6) Uhr bereit sein. Da kamen dann die großen, großen Streifwagen...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . Autos, mit Anhängern eventuell und auf diese wurden die Leute und ihr Gepäck...
David Boder: Anhänger...das nennen wir ‚trailers’.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Oh, ja, ja, ja...und da wurden die Leute darauf verladen...
David Boder: Haben sie die Leute direkt von der Wohnung abgeholt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja.
David Boder: . . . per Adresse?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, die Leute durften ja ihre Wohnungen nicht mehr verlassen. In der Früh erschien dann so ein Auto...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . oder ein Auto mit einem zweiten (2.) Anhänger...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . und man hat die Leute und ihr Gepäck verladen und hat sie in die Sammelstation hin gebracht.
David Boder: Ja und dann?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und in dieser Sammelstation mussten sie nun warten bis der Gesamttransport fertig, hm,...zusammengestellt ist.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Transporte waren gewöhnlich zirka zwei tausend (2000) Menschen stark.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Diese zwei tausend (2000) Menschen sind in der Sammelstation gesammelt worden, das sind ehemalige Heime oder ehemalige Schulen der Kultusgemeinde gewesen und in diesen Heimen hat man die Leute gesammelt und hat sie von dort an einem Tage...oft mussten die Leute acht (8) Tage in diesen...in diesen Heimen bleiben. Sie hatten natürlich nicht die Möglichkeit sich dort zu pflegen, es war unmenschlich...sie wurden zur Not verköstigt. Man hat ihnen ein, ein...etwas Frühstück gegeben, man hat ihnen ein Mittagessen gegeben und ein Nachtmahl gegeben, das hat...
David Boder: Wer hat das besorgt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das hat die Kultusgemeinde durch ihr,...ihre Ausspeisung besorgen lassen.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und nach einigen Tagen wurden die Leute an die Bahnhöfe gefahren und in die Züge verladen.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, Sie haben mir gesagt, Sie haben sich freiwillig gemeldet. Was war das?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Weil man mich...ich habe, ich habe gesagt, ich, ich glaube mich soweit um die jüdische Öffentlichkeit verdient gemacht zu haben, dass ich zumindest die Vergünstigung für mich in Anspruch nehmen darf, dass ich nicht wieder fünf (5) oder sechs (6) oder acht (8) Tage in einem Lager, in dem man Ungeziefer und Läusen ausgesetzt ist und nicht schlafen kann, verbringen muss. Man möchte mich so hin...man möchte mich so einteilen, dass ich nicht mehr wie höchstens ein Nacht und einen Tag in dem Lager verbringe, um nicht mit allzu großer, allzu großen...
David Boder: Schwierigkeiten?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . Schwierigkeiten hinauf zu kommen. Das war der Grund und darum hat man mir gesagt, sie müssen sich bereit halten für diesen und diesen Tag und sie rücken ein in dieses und dieses Heim und das habe ich auch getan.
David Boder: Nun...und da sind Sie mit Ihrer Frau hin gekommen.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Da sind wir am...
David Boder: Wieviel Bagage haben Sie gehabt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Wir hatten...wir hatten...eins (1), zwei (2), zwei (2) große Koffer, zwei (2) kleine Koffer und zwei (2) Bettrollen.
David Boder: Ja...nun.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat gehofft, dass wir diese Bagage auch wirklich hinauf bekommen werden. Man hat versichert, dass es nicht,...dass nichts weg genommen werden wird. Es hat sich anders heraus gestellt. Wir sind am 8. September...sind wir also verladen worden in einen Zug der vom Aspangbahnhof in Wien abgegangen ist und wir sind am neunten (9.) September über Prag in Theresienstadt angekommen.
David Boder: Das waren bloß vier und zwanzig (24) Stunden.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das waren nicht einmal vier und zwanzig (24) Stunden
David Boder: In was für einem Wagen hat man Sie transportiert?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat uns in einem normalem Dritte Klasse Zug...
David Boder: Passagierwagen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Passagierwagen. Sehr eng, eng...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . aber wir konnten...wir konnten das...(unverständliches Murmeln)
David Boder: Wo ist Theresienstadt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Theresienstadt ist etwa sechzig (60) Kilometer nördlich von Prag.
David Boder: Aha, das ist in der Tschechoslowakei?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Zwischen...ja, Prag und der Sächsischen Grenze.
David Boder: Aha...ja, hat das nicht noch einen anderen Namen gehabt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Theresienstadt deutsch, Teresin in...
David Boder: In böhmisch.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . in tschechisch. Nun in Theresienstadt wurden wir...
David Boder: Also erzählen Sie mir einmal über die Ankunft in Theresienstadt, ja?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Ankunft in Theresienstadt...war...sehr traurig. Wir wurden auswagoniert und mussten unser Handgepäck, also das was wir tragen konnten, selbst tragen. Die Großen, nachdem ja ein Mensch höchstens nur zwei (2) Gepäckstücke tragen kann, wurde der große Koffer oder die Bettrolle, die wurden auf...
David Boder: Camion?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Auf Wagen, auf Camion später in die Stadt hereingeführt. Die Bahnstation befindet sich ja ungefähr ½ Gehstunde von Theresienstadt entfernt. Es ist selbstverständlich, dass wir für diesen Weg, das es hauptsächlich alte Leute waren, länger brauchten als eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde. Wir sind über fünf (5) Viertelstunden gegangen und wir haben keinen besonders schönen Anblick geboten...ein Anblick, den ja späterhin in den kommenden Jahren, fast, hm, zu wiederholten Malen in Theresienstadt gesehen haben. Immer wieder die Züge, die neue Ankömmlinge gebracht haben, die schwer beladen unter der Last ihres Gepäcks herein gewankt sind—zu tragen, was sie tragen konnten,weil man sich fürchten musste, dass der größte Teil...weil man weiß...(unverständliches Murmeln)
David Boder: Ihre Frau Gemahlin ist mit Ihnen zusammen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Wir sind wie alle, wir sind so wie alle Anderen da hinein gegangen, hinein gewankt, wir haben uns herein geschleppt. Sind in Theresienstadt dann...sind wir empfangen worden von der Gestapo und von tschechischer Gendarmerie. Man hat unser Gepäck durchsucht und all das weggenommen was verboten war.
David Boder: Und was war verboten?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Verboten war natürlich alles was nach Alkohol auch nur irgendwie gerochen hat, Cognac. Verboten war, hm,...Medikamente, verboten waren Bücher und Zeitungen, mein wunderbares englisches Wörterbuch ist mir als erstes Opfer (lacht etwas) weggenommen worden. Alles was irgend solcher Art war, ist genommen worden.
David Boder: Schmucksachen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Schmucksachen durfte man ja überhaupt nicht mitnehmen. Schmucksachen und Geld—das ist einem schon in Wien gesagt worden—war verboten, man durfte höchstens einen Ehering tragen.
David Boder: Einen Trauring.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Einen Trauring. Sonst durften wir keinerlei Schmucksachen oder Geld mitnehmen. Das Geld haben wir in Wien noch abgeliefert. Was wir an Mark, an Markgeld, Marknoten oder Kleingeld gehabt haben. In Theresienstadt wurden wir, leider Gottes, in die schlechteste Kaserne eingeteilt. Es war...
David Boder: Wieso waren dort Kasernen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: In Theresienstadt...Theresienstadt ist eine alte Festung aus dem...die gebaut worden ist in den Jahre 1770 unter der Zeit Kaiser Josef des Zweiten.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und ist eine,...eine,...hm, ein Ort, der eigentlich nur...wir werden jetzt Schluss machen nicht?
David Boder: Nein, nein, wir werden fortsetzen, es ist nicht Schluss, denn ich will Sie noch am Nachmittag hören.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, ja, ich komme am Nachmittag.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Theresienstadt ist eine Stadt, der nur der militärischen Notwendigkeit ihr Dasein verdankt. Es war eine Stadt die zur Zeit Maria Theresia...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . also zur Zeit Kaiser Josef des Zweiten gebaut worden ist ihrer Gänze und die acht (8) bis zehn (10) große Kasernen enthält...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . mit allem was zu...was an strategischen Außenwerten zur Verteidigung der Festung erforderlich war und ausserdem nach außen hin vollständig abgeschlossen ist durch ein System von Laufgräben, von tiefen Gräben, die durch Wasser durchströmt werden können, die überschwemmt werden können. Also Gräben von einer Tiefe von acht (8) bis zehn (10) Metern und einer Breite von dreißig (30) Metern mit konter (unverständlich), also mit entgegengesetzten Mauern an der Außenseite übergehend in die...in das Vorfeld. Alle diese, alle diese Stellungen Waren Artilleriestellungen...
David Boder: Ah hm.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . auf den Bastionen befand sich die schwere Artillerie und die Gräben waren eben dazu bestimmt, das...
David Boder: Die Stadt zu verteidigen.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . die Stadt einfach vor jedem Sturmangriff zu sichern, denn die Gräben waren inundiert aus dem Fluss Eger und durch diese zwei (2) Meter tiefen Wassergraben konnte zur damaligen Zeit Sturmangriffe nicht vorgetragen werden gegen die Stadt.
David Boder: Also da waren die Kasernen.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Da waren etwa acht (8) große Kasernen und die übrige Stadt zwischen diesen Kasernen bestand aus gewöhnlichen ein Stock hohen Baulichkeiten, in denen all das vorhanden war, war das Militär in der freien Zeit gebraucht hat, also Wirtshäuser, Kaffeehäuser, kleine und größere Geschäfte, Handwerkerladen und alles das, was eben ein Garnison von etwa acht tausend (8000), tausend (8000) Militär vornehmlich hat.
David Boder: Hm.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Häuser sind von der tschechischen Bevölkerung vollständig evakuiert gewesen. In der Zeit, wo wir hinauf gekommen sind, Anfang September neunzehn hundert...
David Boder: Drei...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . neunzehn hundert zwei und vierzig, war die tschechische Bevölkerung schon evakuiert. Allerdings war der Ort nicht in dem Zustand, dass er einer so großen Menge von Menschen eine...die Möglichkeit eines einigermaßen menschlichen Unterkommens gegeben hätte.
David Boder: Was schätzen Sie war die Bevölkerung von...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Bevölkerung Theresienstadt’s war in normalen Zeiten zirka acht tausend (8000) Mann Militär und vier tausend (4000) Zivilbevölkerung, also zwölf tausend (12000) Menschen.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Aus unseren...aus unseren Statistiken weiß ich, dass die Bevölkerung dieses, dieses Judenghettos Theresienstadt zu Zeiten über fünf und sechzig tausend Menschen getragen hat.
David Boder: Aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Also mehr als das Fünffache als der Normalbetrag war. Die Folge dessen war natürlich, dass man die einzelnen Räume so bevölkern musste...
David Boder: Ja, dass...?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . dass man in einem normalen Zimmer von etwa fünf und zwanzig (25 m2) Quadratmetern bis zu zwölf (12) und fünfzehn (15) Menschen unterbringen musste, was nicht anders möglich war, als indem man einfach die Holzbetten über einander bis zu drei (3) angeordnet hat.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das war das denkbar Unhygienischste was man tun konnte, aber nachdem ja das Ziel der Ghetto-isierung doch nur das war, gewünscht möglichst rasch, zu...
David Boder: Vernichten.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . vernichten, so war auch das, sich empfänglich zu machen für Krankheiten aller Art, ein Weg zum Ziel für diese.
David Boder: Wurden Sie dann von Ihrer Frau ab...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Wir wurden selbstverständlich...wir wurden getrennt. Dadurch, dass wir aber die ersten Monate in dieser Jägerkaserne verbracht haben, wo es...wo eine Trennung nicht möglich war, weil sie so gross war, dass man eine (unverständlich) nicht zu machen war, so dass Männlein und Weiblein nebeneinander zusammen untergebracht waren, war die Unterkunft...war die Trennung eine räumliche Trennung gar nicht möglich. Man hat ein...
David Boder: [In English] [interrupting] This concludes Spool 67 of Mr. Schläfrig, from Vienna. We shall continue, I hope with another spool right after noon.
David Boder: [In German] Herr Schläfrig, wollen Sie mit mir essen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Nein, ich danke schön, ich kann (starke Geräusche im Tonband—unverständlich)
David Boder: [In English] Paris...Paris, August 23rd, 1946. This concludes the Spool...67. An Illinois Institute of Technology Wire recording.
David Boder: This is Spool.... this is Spool...this is Spool 68. Mr. Friedrich Schläfer...Schläf...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Schläfrig.
David Boder: . . . Schläfrig continues. We had lunch together and Mr. Schläfrig gave me some.... hm, some more of his background. As he said before he is an engineer, architect, was in Government Service, was retired. He had in the middle ’30s a pension amounting to about six hundred marks, or about one thousand schillings; possibly the equivalent of about two hundred or two hundred fifty American dollars, on which he could live well. His, hm, besides being an engineer—from his retirement he returned to an old hobby.... And that is the construction of violins and a theoretical study of acoustics of wooden instruments in general. As a matter of fact, he intends...he intends in Africa to do something in that line.
David Boder: [In German] Also Herr Schläfrig, Sie haben mir Theresienstadt beschrieben. Nun wollen wir wieder zum Persönlichen übergehen, denn nach all dem kann man ja die Beschreibung von Theresienstadt aus den Literaturen finden und wollen Sie wieder rüber gehen dazu was Ihnen persönlich passiert ist.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Vom Beginn unseres Theresienstädter Aufenthaltes waren wir beide, meine Frau und ich bemüht uns der Allgemeinheit nützlich zu erweisen, so wie wir es uns in Wien schon vorgenommen haben. Dem gerecht haben wir auch beide sofort unsere Position in Theresienstadt bezogen. Meine Frau meldete sich sofort als Hilfsschwester für ein Spital und ich habe die Betreuung von etwa hundert (100) meiner Transportgenossen übernommen mit denen wir zusammen in der sogenannten...in der sogenannten Grenzjägerkaserne einquartiert worden sind. Diese Grenzjägerkaserne war ein uraltes Gebäude, das nur Kasematten enthielt, das heißt gewölbte Räumlichkeiten, die mit Erdreich hoch überschüttet waren, zirka vier (4) bis fünf (5) Meter und über dem Erdreich waren ursprünglich die Artillerie Positionen des Werkes...
David Boder: Das war in den.... in den Kasematten?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und in diesen...diesen Kasematten waren wir untergebracht.
David Boder: Sie waren sozusagen unterirdisch.... unter der Erde...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Untererdlich...ja man hat wohl gesehen...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . das Mauerwerk, aber sie waren von oben...
David Boder: Wie mit einem Berg bedeckt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . wie mit einem Berg, oben war Rasenfläche und...
David Boder: Also waren da Fenster?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Es waren schmale,...es waren schmale, sehr tiefe Räume, Räume die etwas fünf (5) bis sechs (6) Mater breit und gegen vierzig (40) Mater tief waren. An den beiden schmalen Seiten befand sich je ein Doppelfenster. Die Räume war infolgedessen sehr finster. In diesen Kasematten waren nun neunzig (90) bis hundert (100) Menschen in jeder untergebracht. Und in diesen Kasematten mussten auch wir hausen. Wir haben nicht gewusst, dass in dieser Grenzjägerkaserne gleichzeitig ein Spital untergebracht war, das sich neben unseren Kasematten befanden in denen Typhuskranke und Ruhrkranke untergebracht waren.
David Boder: Ruhr...ist das so etwas wie Magentyphus?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ruhr, das ist Dysenterie.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Dysenterie und Typhus...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . und tatsächlich ereigneten sich schon in den ersten Tage schwere Erkrankungsfälle. Schon von den Insassen...von den Insassen der Kasematten starben jeden Tag Einige und in dem Spital, in dem meine Frau Dienst machte, war es selbstverständlich, dass jeden Tag Leute—dort todkrank—ihr Leben dort beschlossen haben. Wir haben in dieser Zeit alles getan, um den Anderen zu helfen. Das Dasein war ein äußerst Trauriges. In der ersten Zeit hatten wir gar nichts auf dem wir liegen konnten. Der Steinboden der Kasematten, den bedeckten wir mit Strohsäcken, die wir später...die wir später erhielten. Wir legten darauf unsere Kleidungsstücke und die mitbrachten Stücke Bettzeug und schafften uns für die Nacht eine notdürftige Liegestatt.
David Boder: Sie hatten zwei (2) Rollbeten mit sich, haben Sie die nicht zurück bekommen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Zwei (2) Bettrollen...
David Boder: Bettrollen...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Bettrollen hatten wir in Theresienstadt bekommen. Sie waren wohl total durchnässt, sind aber wieder getrocknet und wir haben sie wieder in Verwendung genommen.
David Boder: Waren Männer und Frauen zusammen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Männer und Frauen waren zusammen. Es lagen, waren zumeist...zumeist alte Leute, wenig Jugend unter ihnen, höchstens, wenn mit den Eltern irgend ein Sohn oder eine Tochter war. Es waren wenig, wenig jugendliche Leute. Und die alten Leute vielfach so, dass sie schon in den ersten Wochen unter den Lebensbedingungen dorten, zu Grunde gegangen sind. Ausserdem wurde nach acht und nach vierzehn Tage wieder eine Auslese gehalten und ein großer Teil meiner Pflegebefohlenen wurde wieder abgeschickt in polnische Lager. Ich habe sie nie wieder gesehen.
David Boder: Polnische Lager waren was...Treblinka?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die polnischen Lager waren...ich weiß nicht wohin diese Leute gekommen sind...
David Boder: Was für Lager waren das?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das weiß niemand. Sie sind nach Polen hinauf gekommen, ob das Treblinka, ob das Auschwitz war, ob das andere Lager waren, niemand wusste wohin die Transporte hin gegangen sind.
David Boder: Ja. Und man hat nie Briefe von denen bekommen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat nie mehr Briefe von diesen Leuten bekommen. Die, die Insassen, die Insassen dieser Kasematten litten selbstverständlich sehr unter Ungeziefer und unter der Gefahr der Verlausung. Dadurch dass niemand sich echt auskleiden und umkleiden konnte, und dadurch, dass niemand sich richtig waschen konnte...das Waschen nahezu ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit war, haben die...hat die Verlausung zugenommen und da sind tatsächlich Leute in den Kasematten verlaust in ihrem eigenen Kot gestorben. Das Traurigste vom Traurigen des Theresienstädter Aufenthaltes sind diese Wochen in diesen Ruhr- und Typhus verseuchten Kasematten dieser Grenzjägerkaserne. Meine Frau hatte nach zwei Monaten einen Zusammenbruch erlitten, sie war den Anstrengungen der Nachtwache nicht gewachsen und musste diesen Dienst aufgeben und hat einen anderen Dienst übernommen.
David Boder: Was waren die Ärzte, Juden?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Ärzte waren Juden und ich muss sagen, das Beste was man von Theresienstadt sagen kann, ist dass die jüdischen Ärzte wirklich gut waren, dass man gute Ärzte hatte und dass sie—nach Massgabe der Möglichkeit bemüht waren, den Menschen, den Menschen zu helfen. Freilich, es hat sehr bald an Medikamenten gemangelt und die Medikamente, die vorhanden waren, haben nicht ausgereicht für die große Zahl. Ich habe nach etwa zwei Monaten, habe ich die Grenzjägerkaserne mit meiner Frau verlassen. Die Grenzjägerkaserne...
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir mal, ist Ihre Frau jeden Abend zu Ihnen in die Kaserne gekommen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Meine Frau hat...in diesen Kasematten haben Männer und Frauen nebeneinander liegen können, geschlafen...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . so gut es eben gegangen ist und da war eine Trennung der Geschlechter nicht vorgesehen.
David Boder: Aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Es haben in den Kasematten...haben eben achtzig (80) oder neunzig (90) Menschen in einer Kasematte geschlafen, Strohsack und Strohsack, Einer neben dem Anderen. Im Mittelgang in der Nacht wieder Andere, so dass man über die Strohsäcke steigen musste, wenn man hinaus gehen musste zur Latrine.
David Boder: Wo war die Latrine?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Latrine war am Ende der Kasematte in einem jämmerlichen Zustand, so dass einem gegraust hat...dass es wirklich ein Grauen war sie zu benützen.
David Boder: Und haben Frauen und Männer die selbe Latrine benützt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Nein, die Frauen hatten eine Klosett gehabt am anderen Ende des Gebäudes...
David Boder: Hm.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ein Klosett, das natürlich für die große Zahl von zwölf hundert (1200) Menschen, die in dieser Kaserne untergebracht waren, weitaus nicht gereicht hat, ein Klosett mit vier (4) oder fünf (5) Abteilen, so dass die Leute, die Frauen in Schlange gestanden sind, um...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . das Klosett benutzen zu können. Und Männer haben die Latrine am anderen Ende gehabt.
David Boder: Und wie haben sich die Frauen umgezogen oder angekleidet?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Frauen mussten eben...da musste man irgend etwas vor hängen oder haben die Männer eben weg gesehen.
David Boder: Aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich...es war eine besondere Wahrung...man hat sich an Vieles gewöhnt in diesen Verhältnissen.
David Boder: Nun...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die...
David Boder: Was hat man mit den toten Leuten getan, die gestorben sind?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die sind in eine...in eine andere Kasematte zusammen gelegt worden. Die Leichen sind dann einen Tag oder zwei (2)Tage später abgeholt worden zur Beerdigung. Es waren in diesen Zeiten...waren durch diese Ruhr- und Typhus Epidemie, hat so viele Opfer gekostet, dass in einer Nacht zwei hundert zwanzig (220) und zwei hundert vierzig (240) Menschen gestorben sind.
David Boder: Wo, in den Kasematten oder?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Nein,...in Theresienstadt.
David Boder: Nein, ich meine sind sie im Spital gestorben oder in der Kasematte?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Nein, in den Kasematten.
David Boder: In den Kasematten.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Spitäler konnte diese vielen Menschen gar nicht aufnehmen. Man ist...man ist so gelegen, dass man, dass Einer vom Anderen nicht wusste. Mein Nachbar...ist in der Nacht verschieden...in der Früh war er tot.
David Boder: Ja,...aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das...das Sterben war eine leichte Angelegenheit unter diesen Verhältnissen.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, hat man irgendwelche religiöse Befriedigung gehabt? Haben sie erlaubt, dass die Leute beten, eine Minje, eine Synagoge??
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja...es ist in kurzer Zeit...in kurzer Zeit haben sich...haben sich die Möglichkeiten geboten, dass ganz regelrechte Gebetsstunden in Bethäusern und Synagogen abgehalten wurden. Es wurden Räumlichkeiten zu Synagogen umgewandelt und die Gebetsstunden normal eingehalten. Es hat immer Andacht gegeben während der ganzen Zeit und immer genügend viel Juden gegeben, die an den Andachten teilgenommen haben.
David Boder: Erinnern Sie sich an welche Rabbiner in Theresienstadt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, ich erinnere mich an Dr. Neustadt...
David Boder: Von wo?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Meines Wissens aus Frankfurt am Main.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Dr. Leo Beck von Berlin.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Sonst sind mir augenblicklich Namen nicht...
David Boder: Die Namen...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . in der Erinnerung.
David Boder: Waren dort welche jüdische Schauspieler oder Künstler?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Es war eine ganze Anzahl von jüdischen Schauspielern...hm,...dort, ich...jüdische Schauspieler, jüdische Künstler und zwar sowohl als Klavier Künstler, wie Violin Virtuosen, wie, hm, Schauspieler selbst, Sänger, Sängerinnen; dann Filmleiter, Film Leute, Regisseure vom Film...
David Boder: Hm.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Es hat nicht am kulturellen Leben gefehlt. Natürlich in den ersten Monaten...
David Boder: Haben die Instrumente mit gehabt...hat es Instrumente gegeben?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Wir hatten sehr wenig...in der ersten Zeit sind überhaupt keine Instrumente da gewesen und es hat sich...das kulturelle Leben hat sich erst entwickelt, wie die, hm, wie die ganze Verwaltung Theresienstadt’s in geregelte Bahnen geleitet worden ist. Das hat immerhin das ganze erste Jahr meines dortigen Aufenthaltes in Anspruch genommen. Denn im ersten Jahr mussten die Verhältnisse zumindestens so geschaffen werden, dass die Menschen leben konnten. Wir haben in Theresienstadt keine Wasserleitung gehabt. Wenn fünf und sechzig tausend (65,000) Menschen in so einen kleinen Ort gedrängt untergebracht werden und angewiesen sind auf die Brunnen, auf das Wasser, dann ist es naheliegend, dass bei der Kommunikation zwischen den Abteil (unverständlich), und der Brunnen sich in kurzer Zeit, hm, das Typhose Fieber einstellen musste. Und das ist auch der Fall gewesen, wir mussten viele der Brunnen sperren und mussten die vorhandene Wasserleitung ausbauen. Das war eigentlich eines der größten Werke, das die jüdischen Techniker mit den jüdischen Arbeitern geschaffen haben. Die haben das Wasserwerk ausgebaut und haben es so weit gebracht, dass wir endlich den Leuten nicht nur gutes Trinkwasser, na wenigstens hygienisch einwandfreies Trinkwasser, schaffen konnten, sondern dass wir auch die Klosettanlagen mit Wasserspülung versehen konnten, so dass diese unhygienischen Einrichtungen beseitigt worden sind.
David Boder: Und die Deutschen haben das erlaubt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Deutschen haben das erlaubt und wir haben sogar Material durch sie bekommen, weil sonst wären die Verhältnisse in Theresienstadt einfach unhaltbar gewesen wären.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Nachher...
David Boder: Sie sagten Dr. Friedmann war in Theresienstadt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Friedmann und Stricker—beide waren in Theresienstadt. Friedmann war, war Leiter des finanziellen Dienstes, das ist...
David Boder: In Theresienstadt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das ist...des Ghettos. Das heißt später hat man nicht mehr gesagt „Jüdisches Ghetto Theresienstadt“, sondern „ Jüdische Selbstverwaltung Theresienstadt“.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und Friedmann war Leiter des finanzielles Dienstes in Theresienstadt...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . und er hat diese Abteilung geführt. Und auch Stricker war unter den...war im Ältestenrat. Beide haben sich, haben sich eingesetzt und haben viel gearbeitet.
David Boder: Und was hat mit denen passiert?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Friedmann und Stricker sind im Jahre 1944...sind sie mit ihren Frauen in einen Transport gekommen, der nach Auschwitz gegangen ist und sind, meines Wissens, dort verbrannt worden. Sie haben Tote...(Rest unverständliches Murmeln)
David Boder: Nun...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Wir haben in Theresienstadt keine Gaskammern gehabt, aber wir haben solche Gaskammern in den letzten Monaten der Nazi Herrschaft auch in Theresienstadt errichtet.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Gas Kammern, die ihrer Benützung aber niemals zugeführt worden sind.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man spricht davon, dass der letzte Leiter der Gestapo in Theresienstadt, man spricht davon...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich weiß es nicht, ob es mehr ist als ein Geschwätz...man spricht davon, dass der letzte Leiter von Theresienstadt selbst es gewesen wäre, der, hm, der bekannt gegeben...der dem Roten Kreuz bekannt gegeben hätte, dass auch in Theresienstadt die Errichtung von Gaskammern und die Vergasung der Insassen beabsichtigt sei und dass er sich ausgebeten hätte, dass für diese Rettung der Theresienstädter Juden man ihm die freie, freie Ausreise nach der Schweiz ermöglichen solle.
David Boder: Hat man das getan?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ob man das getan hat, weiß ich nicht. Ober Mann hinaus gekommen ist oder nicht, weiß ich nicht...
David Boder: Was war der Name?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Der Name war Rahm.
David Boder: Rahm. Was war er...ein Sturmführer?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Er war ein SS Obersturmführer Rahm...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Meines Wissens ein Wiener.
David Boder: Aha, nun?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Diese, hm, die Grenzjägerkaserne ist ja nach zwei (2) Monaten...um mein persönliches Schicksal weiter zu...
David Boder: Ja, das hätten wir gerne gehabt.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . zu ergänzen, ist nach zwei Monaten wegen der gänzlichen...wegen der Notwendigkeit der gänzlichen Desinfizierung gegen Verlausung und anderes Ungeziefer, geräumt worden. Und man hat die Insassen auf andere (unverständlich) verteilt. Wir selbst sind dann in ein sogenanntes Block Haus, das sind also die einstöckigen, privaten Wohngebäude in Theresienstadt, übersiedelt, wo wir, meine Frau und zwölf (12) oder vierzehn (14) andere Frauen und ich mit elf (11) anderen Männern, ein Zimmer bewohnt haben, in dem wir eben den ganzen Winter über von zwei und vierzig (42) auf drei und vierzig (43) gehaust haben. Angesichts der Notwendigkeit der Fliegerangriffe alle Räumlichkeiten streng zu verdunkeln, unter strengen Strafen der wir für das Unterlassen der Verdunkelung ausgesetzt waren, war es für die Insassen nicht möglich in der Nacht die Schlafräume mit frischer Luft zu versehen. Die Nächte waren also qualvoll. Ich habe, zum Beispiel, von ein Uhr nachts an nicht mehr genug Luft gehabt, um atmen zu können. Und ich habe diese ganze Zeit von ein Uhr nachts bis zum Morgen wach verbracht und habe mich immer nur gefreut, wenn einer der Insassen gezwungen war einen gewissen Ort zu benützen und somit die Tür aufmachte und von dem Stiegenhaus etwas frische Luft hereingekommen ist.
David Boder: Was ist denn das Stiegenhaus?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das Stiegenhaus ist der Aufgang, die Treppe zum ersten Stock, weil mein Zimmer im ersten Stock war; das Zimmer meiner Frau war auf ebener Erde. Wir sind dann nachdem,...hm, nach...im Frühjahr neun zehn hundert und drei und vierzig (1943) wurden, wurden die Insassen von Theresienstadt gesiebt. Die Gestapo hat Unterschiede gemacht und hat prominente Persönlichkeiten ausgeschieden. Und hat diesen prominenten Persönlichkeiten eine etwas bessere Unterkunft bereitet. So dass die Menschen, die man in die Klasse der Prominenten eingereiht hat, dass die gewöhnlich zu zweit—eine Familie: Mann und Frau—ein Zimmer bekommen haben und für sich wohnen konnten und auch eine, eine, hm, bessere...eine bessere...
David Boder: Verpflegung?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . Verpflegung bekommen haben. Aber die große...es waren...es waren gar nicht allzu Viele, es waren vielleicht hundert fünfzig (150)...
David Boder: Waren Sie darunter?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . zwei hundert Prominente. Nein, ich bin nicht dabei gewesen.
David Boder: Sie waren nicht unter den Prominenten?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich war nicht unter den Prominenten. Unter den Prominenten war Murmelstein.
David Boder: Murmelstein, der in Wien war?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Murmelstein war unter den Prominenten. Einige von seinen Leuten aus der Kultusgemeinde, die er mit gebracht hat, wurden unter die Prominenten eingereiht durch seine Mitwirkung...
David Boder: Wieso wurde Murmelstein überhaupt verschickt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Eines schönen Tages hat ihn die Gestapo herauf geschickt mit seinen Getreuen und seinen Jüngern.
David Boder: Aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Gründe sind mir nicht bekannt. Also diese Prominenten, es waren ja nicht allzu viele, zirka ein hundert fünfzig (150) bis zwei hundert (200). Die großen Massen, an dem Schicksal der übrigen großen Massen hat sich nicht viel geändert. Auch waren die Prominenten...auch waren die Prominenten bis zu einem gewissen Grade vor dem Schicksal des...der, der weiteren Deportierung nach polnischen Lagern bewahrt.
David Boder: Also Friedmann war nicht unter den Prominenten und...?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Friedmann, Friedmann...
David Boder: Und Stricker.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Friedmann, ja, Friedmann und Stricker, ja, waren auch unter den Prominenten, haben aber...haben aber für sich in einem Haus gewohnt, wo sonst nur Prominente gewohnt haben. Friedmann und Stricker waren unter den Prominenten.
David Boder: Und nachher waren sie weggeschickt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und wurden trotzdem weggeschickt.
David Boder: Und Sie waren unter den Prominenten nicht?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich war nicht unter den Prominenten und bin allerdings auch in Transporte gekommen und zwei Mal, ich muss sagen, hm, durch ein Gefüge des Schicksals oder wirklich, hm, Gottes Hilfe...
David Boder: Willen.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . Willen aus den Transporten wieder ausgereiht worden.
David Boder: Also wollen wir dann weiter gehen , ja nun...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja.
David Boder: Kommen Sie zu Ihrer persönlichen Geschichte jetzt zurück.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ich habe...Ich habe im November...im November neunzehn hundert zwei und vierzig (1942), habe ich mich dem technischen Dienst zur Verfügung gestellt und habe im technischen Dienst gearbeitet. Ich habe schon erwähnt, dass wir das Wasserwerk...das Wasserwerk einrichten mussten, beziehungsweise die bestehende Wasserversorgung für den weit...für die große Bevölkerung, hm, hm, leistungsfähig ausgestalten mussten, neue Wsserleitungsstränge durch alle Strassen legen mussten, arbeiten an großen Rohrlegungsarbeiten. Wir mussten aber nicht nur das, wir mussten die Häuser so Instand setzen, dass sie vom sanitären Standpunkt aus nicht allzu viel zu wünschen lassen, das hat uns viel beschäftigt. Und dann mussten wir Vorsorge treffen, da wir viele der Dachböden in den Häusern belegen mussten, weil die Stockwerke nicht Platz genug gehabt haben, um die Leute unter zu bringen, mussten wir für die, für allfällige Feuergefahr, für die Bekämpfung der Feuergefahr vorsorgen. Es musste also eine Feuerwehr ins Leben gerufen werden,...die Gestapo hat uns eine Motorspritze und zwei (2) andere Feuerspritzen verschafft. Es wurde eine richtige Feuerwehr unter einem Feuerwehrkommandanten gebildet und wir mussten...wir mussten auch eine Feuerpolizei einrichten, die immer zu delegieren hatte, damit die Multiplikationen vom Feuer Standpunkt aus einwandfrei sind. Wir mussten eine Feuerlöschordnung schaffen und das hat uns einige Monate beschäftigt. Wir mussten dann eine Unmenge anderer technischer Arbeiten machen, die eben mit der Verwaltung eines, eines, hm, solchen Unsummen von Baulichkeiten verbunden sind. Ausserdem...und das hat natürlich den technischen Dienst sehr stark beschäftigt—hat die Gestapo mit ihren Angehörigen und dem ganzen Kommando der Gestapo größten Wert darauf gelegt, dass ihre Unterkünfte in dem glänzendesten Zustand sind. Man hat fortwährend zu Bauen gehabt, sie haben fortwährend Wünsche gehabt. Es war ihnen nichts gut genug, denn die Herren von der Gestapo haben in Theresienstadt in ihren Ubikationen, in ihren Räumlichkeiten—das war ein eigener Teil der Stadt, der abgegrenzt war für die Gestapo allein, mit großen Parkanlagen, sehr schönen, modernen und den besten Gebäuden, die Theresienstadt hatte; da mussten wunderbare Einrichtungen geschaffen werden für die Unterhaltung der Herren von der Gestapo—Kaffeehäuser, Restaurants, ein Kinosaal, ein Grossartiger, Klubräume...alles musste von uns geschaffen werden. Und das hat natürlich einen großen Teil der Bauarbeiten verursacht und der technische Dienst zu machen hatte. Und so...
David Boder: Und bei dieser Verbindung mit der Gestapo waren die freundlich, waren die...? (unverständlich—beide sprechen).
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Gestapo hatte eigentlich mit dem größten Teil der Juden nichts zu tun gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Mit der Gestapo war man froh, wenn man sie nicht gesehen hat. Man ist...man hatte natürlich auf den Strassen ein Prompt zu machen und sie zu begrüßen....
David Boder: Hm.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ebenso hatte man auch die tschechische Gendarmerie zu grüßen, denn...
David Boder: Oh!
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . denn die waren ja die Wachmannschaft deren sich die Gestapo bedient hat. Alle Ausgänge und alle Eingänge in die Stadt waren ja von der tschechischen Gendarmerie bewacht.
David Boder: Aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Also die Insassen hatten die Verpflichtung jeden, hm, zu grüßen von diesen Leuten, ohne...diese Leute hatten aber ein striktes Dankverbot. Sie durften nicht danken.
David Boder: Wer?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die tschechische Gendarmerie durfte nicht und die Gestapo hat natürlich nicht gedankt. Sie sind mit ihren Reitpeitschen und mit ihren großen Stiefeln durch die Stadt gegangen und es ist ihnen jeder ausgewichen, der sie nur gesehen hat.
David Boder: Oh, sie durften nicht danken, wenn man sie grüßte...?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Nein.
David Boder: Sie durften nicht zurück grüßen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Sie durften nicht zurück grüßen, haben auch nie zurück gegrüßt. Man war froh, wenn man nichts mit ihnen zu tun hatte. Leider ist es aber doch vorgekommen, wenn Leute unvorsichtig waren, die Chauffeure der Gestapo sind in der rücksichtslosesten Weise mit ihren Traktoren und mit ihren Auto gefahren und es sind ja ziemlich viele Fälle vorgekommen, wo Leute überfahren worden sind, weil sie nicht rechtzeitig ausweichen konnten. Man hat sogar gesagt, dass einer der Chauffeure es darauf angelegt hat, Juden zu überfahren. Na, man darf das ja nur so nebenbei...
David Boder: Nun.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Der...der technische Dienst hat, hm, hat eine...hat also großen Umfang angenommen gehabt, weil große...weil tatsächlich die Arbeiten, die von dem technischen Dienst verlangt wurden, sehr umfangreich waren. Wie das Jahr neun zehn hundert vier und vierzig (1944) erscheint man in den Kreisen der Gestapo den Auftrag bekommen zu haben, Theresienstadt in ein Musterlager zu gestalten.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das heißt, aus Theresienstadt ein Lager zu machen, das man den Presseleuten und eventuell dem Roten Kreuz zeigen konnte. Und da ist auf einmal der Befehl ergangen, die Stadt zu verschönern. Vom Jahre vier und vierzig (44) an hat der technische Dienst eine Unsumme von Arbeiten gehabt, um diese Stadtverschönerung durchzuführen. Alles musste in Stand gesetzt werden, alles musste verputzt werden und gefärbelt werden, die Strasse mussten peinlich sauber gehalten werden. Es durfte kein Papierschnitzel weg geworfen werden. Es war auch tatsächlich ein ziemlich reinliches Örtchen. Die Kasernen mussten zum Teil geräumt werden, weil die Gestapo ein großes Zentralarchiv aus Deutschland irgendwo—eine ganze Kartothek der Parteiangehörigen nach, hm, nach Theresienstadt verlegt hat.
David Boder: Hm, nach Theres...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Wir mussten also eine große Kaserne, die mussten binnen wenigen Tagen geräumt werden und die ganzen Räumlichkeiten mussten für dieses Archiv Instand gesetzt werden. Nach wenigen Wochen ist das Archiv auch tatsächlich...ist das, ist das installiert worden und das ist von Gestapo Organen, hm, ist das bedient worden. Da hatten dann die Juden nicht mehr Zutritt, nur die, die mit ihrer dienstlichen Eigenschaft dort zu tun hatten—die Betreuung, die Leute, die die Ofen beheizt haben,...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . Leute, die irgendwelche Arbeiten...
David Boder: Aber keine Kanzlei Arbeiten?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Keinerlei Kanzlei Arbeiten, das war für Juden dann gesperrt. Das Jahr vier und vierzig (44) stand also unter dem Zeichen „Stadtverschönerung“. Wir haben wiederholt Besuche gehabt von ausländischen Pressevertretern, es war...
David Boder: Zum Beispiel...es waren doch nicht viele Ausländer, die nicht im Krieg waren, Schweden, Schweiz...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, offenbar nur die, die in Deutschland noch...die in Deutschland noch ihre Pressevertreter hatten.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und es ist weise untergangen keinerlei Antworten zu geben, net wahr, außer das was die Gestapo fragt. Also man durfte auf die Fragen, die eventuell die Pressevertreter gestellt hätten, durfte gar keine Antwort gegeben werden.
David Boder: Konnten die Pressevertreter die Leute sehen?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, die Pressevertreter haben die Leute gesehen, aber man hat ihnen natürlich nur dasjenige gezeigt, man hat sie nur dort hin geführt—der Rundgang war im Vorhinein fest gelegt nach einer ganz bestimmten roten Linie—und es sind den Pressevertretern...
David Boder: Was für eine rote Linie, war die aufgezeichnet?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ja, im Plan.
David Boder: Oh, ja, im Plan...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . eine rote Linie und die sind diesen Weg gegangen und alle die Ubikationen, die im Besichtigungsplan waren, mussten „auf den Glanz“, wie man sagt, hergerichtet werden.
David Boder: Und dann?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Sie mussten sich also sehr repräsentieren, dass kein Einwand war.
David Boder: Nun?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das ist, das ist einige Male vorkommen, wenn...und um, um den, um den Pressevertretern mehr zu zeigen, hat man in dieser Zeit auch Geschäfte eingerichtet, man hat Ghetto Geld drucken lassen..., Ghetto Dollar...
David Boder: Ghetto Dollar oder Mark?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Dollar.
David Boder: No!
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Richtige Ghetto Dollars, Theresienstädter Ghetto Dollars.
David Boder: Ja?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: In Einheiten von eins bis, hm, zu hundert (100), glaube ich.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Ghetto Geld...und dieses Geld haben die Arbeitenden verdient. Alle diejenigen, die irgendwelche Arbeiten für die Gemeinschaft geleistet haben, sind in Ghetto Dollar entlohnt worden.
David Boder: Was haben sie gekauft?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und da hat man, um das potentinische Dorf vollständig richtig darzustellen, hat man nun Geschäfte errichtet und in diesen Geschäften konnten die Insassen des Ghettos alles Mögliche kaufen, was die Geschäfte bekommen haben.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Vorwiegend waren es durchaus diejenigen Waren, die man aus...die man den jüdischen Transportteilnehmern, die man aus den Koffern, die man zurückbehalten hat, genommen hat.
David Boder: Aha.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat den Leuten, die nach Theresienstadt gekommen sind, in den seltensten Fällen ihr großes Gepäck gelassen. Man hat einfach die großen Koffer unter Verschluss behalten und jede Woche sind so und so viel Hunderte von den Koffern, Tausende von den Koffern und das, was man an Wäschestücken und an Kleidungsstücken und an sonstigen, hm, Geräten, die man in den Koffern gefunden hat, das hat man in eine Kaserne, das war die sogenannte Aussiger Kaserne in Depot gegeben. In dieser Aussiger Kaserne ist alles...all das...all das Hab und Gut der jüdischen Ghetto Insassen aufgestapelt worden. Ich selbst habe wiederholt dort zu tun gehabt, weil ich die Stellagen, in denen die Waren aufgeschlichtet wurden, weil ich die bauen musste und verstärken musste, weil sie überlastet worden sind.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Das größte Lager.... Es hat keine Wäschefabrik Deutschlands, ich glaube nicht...keine Wäschefabrik der Welt ein, ein so großes Lager von Herrenhemden oder Frauenhemden oder dergleichen, wie ich in der Aussiger Kaserne in Theresienstadt gesehen habe. Es waren dort—ohne dass man übertreibt—Hunderttausend von Wäschestücken jeder einzelnen Art...nicht nur dass in dieser Kaserne das Gepäck...das in dieser Aussiger Kaserne das Gepäck der Insassen von Theresienstadt...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . geschleust worden ist, wie man sagt...also...
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . wird und sortiert worden ist, man hat aus...aus allen anderen Städten Deutschlands hat man den Juden abgenommen das Gepäck, hin geschickt nach Theresienstadt und dort ist das paketiert und sortiert worden, um wieder in das Reich—die verschiedenen Städte geschickt zu werden für die Menschen, die ausgebombt sind und Mangel an Wäschestücken und Kleidung haben. Es war ein ungeheueres Lager an Kleidungsstücken, Wäschestücken, Schuhen, an Bedarfsartikeln jeglicher Art.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Und mit einem Teil dieser Vorräte hat man nun die Geschäfte ausgestattet und die Juden konnten nun für ihre Ghetto Dollars die Waren kaufen, die man den Juden abgenommen hat.
David Boder: Ja.
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Natürlich waren vielfach sehr schöne Waren dort, sehr gute Waren, aber die Protektion hat hier eine Rolle gespielt...und für gute Verbindung hat man gute Waren bekommen. Wer keine Verbindung gehabt hat, hat keine Waren bekommen oder schlechte Ware.
David Boder: Und wer hat diese Geschäfte bedient?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Die Geschäfte sind wieder von den Juden bedient worden. Die haben wieder...der Eine war der Geschäftsleiter...das Andere waren Angestellte im Geschäft...Juden und Jüdinnen waren dort Verkäufer und Verkäuferinnen. Und dann hat man, um das Bild einer Gemeinschaft voll zu machen, hat man auch für Gesellschaftsqualitäten Sorge getragen. Man hat also...man hat also ein Kaffeehaus geschaffen und im Kaffeehaus wur..., wurden Konzerte abgehalten. Von...über Kommando der Gestapo musste das Ghetto eine jüdische Musikkapelle aufstellen. Es haben sich genug Musiker gefunden, man hat Instrumente dazu dirigiert und es...und es wurde im Kaffeehaus konzertiert. Man hat in Parkanlagen, die aus dem Boden gestampft werden mussten im Zuge der Verschönerung, zu arbeiten...hat man einen Musik-Pavillon errichtet, wo allabendlich Konzerte waren, die übrigens gar nicht schlecht waren und wo die jüdischen Musiker tatsächlich recht gute...recht Gutes geleistet haben. Es hat auch...es sind auch alle Bestrebungen unterstützt worden, die...die in der freien Zeit den Arbeitenden und den alten Leuten...hm, Erholung bieten sollten; also man. hat für Vorträge Sorge getragen, es haben sich Ausschüsse gebildet für die Freizeit Ausgestaltung, Vortragsgemeinschaften, es wurden Sprachkurse abgehalten, es wurden wissenschaftliche Vorträge, also in allen möglichen Gebieten abgehalten—in technischen Gebieten, medizinischen Gebieten, religiösen Gebieten. Es hat auf allen Gebieten ein ziemlich reges Leben gegeben. Es wurden Theaterstücke gespielt, es haben sich die Schauspieler zusammen gefunden. Man hat auf den Dachböden Bühnen inszeniert und den Zuschauerraum inszeniert...es ist...es ist also ein ziemlich lebhaftes, geistliches Leben langsam und langsam in Schwung gekommen. Das war im Jahre vier und vierzig (44) und, hm, in dieser Zeit hätte es für den oberflächlichen Betrachter das Leben der Juden in Theresienstadt ein ganzes Leben eigentlich gewesen.
David Boder: In den meisten Fällen...
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Aber man...
David Boder: . . . haben Männer und Frauen zusammen gelebt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: . . . aber man darf...die Wenigsten haben zusammen gelebt, sie waren getrennt in Männer und Frauen. Das wäre es ja nicht gewesen, das, was den Theresienstädter Aufenthalt so fürchterlich gemacht hat, war die Unruhe, weil man nicht gewusst hat wer von heute auf morgen dort bleiben wird.
David Boder: Wie oft hat man Leute weggeschickt?
Friedrich Schlaefrig: Man hat jede Woche Transporte weggeschickt, mit Ausnahme eines kurzen Zeitraumes in der Weihnachtszeit und in der Osterzeit. Mit Ausnahme dieser zwei Zeiten sind...haben immer Transporte nach Polen stattgefunden aus den verschiedensten Gegenden Deutschlands und der...und der Tschechoslowakei.